thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement i think i had almost as much
notice as the cabinet
[Laughter]
can i also thank
can i also thank everybody who works in
the nhs and social care
during mr speaker during the darkest
days of the pandemic they kept our
health service from collapsing they
looked after the elderly when others
couldn't and they rolled out the vaccine
which has finally provided the light at
the end of the tunnel despite their
efforts we're facing the toughest winter
in the history of our health service not
only do we have the threat of another
coveted surge
waiting list for diagnosis and treatment
have reached record levels we risk
cancer survival rates going backwards
for the first time ever and social care
remains neglected and strained it is a
crisis
but how did we get here mr speaker
the pandemic has undoubtedly placed the
nhs under huge strain
but that is only part of the story
[Music]
a decade of conservative neglect
weakened the nhs
waiting lists had spiraled up 2 million
before the pandemic
targets were missed on cancer on a e on
mental health before the pandemic
the same is true mr speaker on social
care eight billion pounds cut despite
growing demand before the pandemic
carers on poverty wages without secure
contract before the pandemic yeah a
hundred thousand vacancies before the
pandemic
and the prime minister has just
referenced the 30 000 hospital beds
occupied by those that should go into
the community and he called that this is
before the pandemic an indictment of
failure
who had been in government for 10 years
just remind me
an indictment
prime minister
we an indictment of failure is an
accurate description of the situation in
our health surface and social care
before the pandemic so the pretense that
the prime minister is only here
because of the pandemic is not going to
wash he's putting a sticking plaster
over gaping wounds which his party
inflicted
he made that commitment on social care
before the pandemic and he said he would
pay for it without raising taxes before
the pandemic
yes
yes mr speaker the nhs urgently needs
more investment
but the backlog will not be cleared
unless the government hits the 18-week
target set out in the nhs constitution
the prime minister didn't mention that
it was set and it was met by the last
labour government
so if there's to be improvements prime
minister a direct question
can the prime minister commit today
to hitting the target and clearing the
backlog by the end of this parliament
yes or no i know he know he likes to
avoid these questions but if he can't
answer that basic question
it's clear he hasn't got a plan
turning
turning to social care
mr speaker turning to social care under
these proposals people will still face
substantial costs and i heard what the
prime minister says so another direct
question for him can the prime minister
guarantee
that under his plan no one will have to
sell their home to fund their own care
yes or no
but social care well he just told us
let's hear him make that commitment at
the dispatch box that no one under his
plan will have to sell their own home to
fund their own care and then we'll come
back to it
but social care mr speaker is about so
much more than this
the blunt the blunt and uncomfortable
truth is that under the prime minister's
plans the quality of care received will
not improve there's no plan for that
people will still go without the care
that they need there's no plan for that
unpaid family carers will still be
pushed to breaking point there's no plan
for that working age adults with
disabilities will have no more control
onto their lives there's no plan for
that
pay and conditions will not improve for
care workers there's no plan for that
let me spell that out
let me spell that out a poorly paired k
work a poorly paired k work care worker
will pay more tax
for the care that they're providing
without a penny more in their pay packet
and without a secure contract
[Music]
the prime minister shakes his head my
sister is a poorly paid care worker
prime minister so i know this first hand
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a tax rise
that breaks a promise
that the prime minister made at the last
election
a promise that they all made
at the last election every single one of
them
a tax rise a tax rise on young people
supermarket workers and nurses yeah a
tax rise mr speaker that means a
landlord renting out dozens of
properties won't pay a penny more
but the tenants working in full-time
jobs would a tax rise that places
another burden on business just as
they're trying to get back on their feet
mr speaker read my lips the tories could
never again claim to be the party of low
the alternative mr speaker is obvious a
timetable and plan to clear waiting
lists just as we did under the last
labour government a comprehensive reform
plan for social care dealing with the
inadequacies i've just pointed out and
driving up the equality of provision
and not just tinkering with the funding
model
we do need to ask those with the broader
shoulders to pay more
and that does include
asking much more of wealthier people
including income from stocks from shares
from dividends and from property
[Applause]
chancellor i was listening i was
listening but fiddling and the
chancellor knows the numbers just as
well as i do he'll have done the sums
and we've done them
tinkering and fiddling
tinkering and fiddling with the dividend
won't do that instead the government is
placing the primary burden on working
people and businesses struggling to get
by
as i've said to the prime minister if
the government comes forward with a plan
to genuinely fix the price in social
care
and has a fair funding model the end we
will work together thousands of families
struggling with the current system
who only want the best of their loved
ones deserve nothing less thank you